is someone killing american national
pride oh absolutely it's the left and
it's been a coordinated effort for at
least the last two decades
and honestly i i remember back in about
2001 in fact
that i was kind of a part of it without
knowing it um
when when the twin towers had been uh
blown up uh crashed planes into
collapsed um
there was this distinct feeling
that this was unacceptable american
nationalism when george bush was there
on the ruins with an american flag and
people chanting usa right there was
there was a distinct feeling
uh on the left that this was scary and
this was going to lead to fascism this
was going to be
and don't wrong i don't approve of any
of the consequences of
911 or 911 itself i didn't support the
invasion of
iraq or anything like that um and there
there were obviously terrible
consequences from that
but um but i think this has been that
was the flash point that started the
left on
a sort of conscious attempt to undermine
american patriotism
and uh and i think that that has been
successful
i think that much of the left now openly
admit that they hate america they think
it's an imperialist white supremacist
power
capitalism is inherently a racist
structure that's designed to oppress
people
and the communists who have been pushing
this view of the world
have been very very successful in
planting the seeds in the left
and destroying the patriotic left the
sort of
you know the sort of working class left
who actually like america and just want
the rich to give them a bit of the pie
those people have been totally
marginalized and now it's
whites versus blacks or you know
straights versus gays and all the so
now it doesn't really reflect actually
what's happening because
i don't agree that there's a race war
going on i don't agree there's a gender
war going on you know i don't agree that
straight people are waging war against
gay people
and trying to keep them down that's just
not my experience of life and maybe i'm
talking from a position of privilege
being a straight white man but the only
the only gender or race war or
like sexuality war that i see is being
waged by the left you know so
i think i think the left have done this
quite self-consciously in many ways
i think in the uk we're already used to
kind of british national pride being
silma's seen as the realm of
racists and working-class thugs right
like hanging a flag ups the sort of
thing
that the community watch ring the
council about and you get
absolutely get people around to your
house i wonder if america will end up
like that i fear not
i don't think that they will i think
that it's too strong that patriotism
it's been very very very ingrained but
the left do
definitely seem like they're making a
good job of trying to deconstruct that
yeah i mean they're very good at playing
the long game so in
in 2001 it didn't look like there was
any possibility of demolishing american
patriotism but here we are going well
god and the americans even going to be
patriotic next year
you know so it's only been 20 years so
it doesn't take that long it doesn't
take that long in the grand scheme of
things
and you're right obviously over here
it's gross how unpatriotic we're allowed
to be
this is why i've got the flag behind me
i'm not naturally a flag flying guy
like this you know it's not something i
would naturally do but in the current
circumstances given the current context
oh yeah we're having a british flag
you know and uh and if we get told off
for that an english flag goes up as well
if that's what they want you know i'm
i'm not backing down on this you know i
i bought an english flag a while ago for
the first time ever and i was like okay
what do i do with it now
you know do i go and flights outside my
house is that gonna be imposing on the
neighbors i don't know
but uh but i bought it just say i had it
because i'm sick of the
genuinely anti-patriotic feeling that
the left is pumping out and it's because
they're essentially communist now
socialist or communist which is
essentially a synonym
and they they view
national pride as a form of false
consciousness they view
national pride as a barrier to communism
which it is
uh which is why we should support and
uphold it which is why you should get a
flag
yeah fair point it is bizarre like you
go through
you go to gyms go to a crossfit gym in
in america
and you'll see hanging from the ceiling
there'll be us marine
navy core there'll be the
red white and blue star spangled banner
and there'll be like some other stuff as
well and you just think like there's
such a at least this was
three years ago might have changed now
yeah um it just felt like there's such a
cohesive i
actually got quite jealous i had like um
country jealousy
in a way where i was like man i've never
have you ever heard anyone say
i am proud to be a british citizen like
i'm proud to be british you know
like saying the sentence i'm proud to be
british
sounds like it's something that comes
out of that muslim ray gangs
uh video from a few years two two two
two places right uh none of it neither
of them in britain
the first one the the first one not hong
kong
and nearly uh i i grew up on a military
base in
germany uh obviously it was called joint
headquarters jhq is there much in
gladbach
or it was it's been decommissioned now
um but there
that again when you're when you're in
close contact with the foreign culture
um you become very much aware of your
own culture and its strengths and
weaknesses and the virtues and vices of
it
and then you become a lot more
self-reflective
about the thing and so you you it wasn't
you know it wasn't like you know
chess beating nationalism or anything
but you know that was the sort of vibe
that had them because it was a military
base you'd have you know the flag and
things like that on flagpoles you know
so
it felt more patriotic and uh the other
the only other place i felt this is in
gibraltar
when i went over there for the mep tour
um it was
like a a very beautiful british village
that's been transplanted to the south of
spain
and there were british flags everywhere
and it was lovely you know because the
weather was amazing for a start
and everyone was really nice you know
everything was really relaxed and
friendly and those
british flags everywhere and everything
was very patriotic wasn't it callum you
know callum went with me was great um
and uh and we had a great time there and
it just felt very nice
very relaxed and you know it was
wholesome
it was good but they're the only two
places not in britain so bizarre man
[Music]
you